TIERNEY LETS IT GO, KASTELIC
THROWS IT ON NET
AND HE'S GETTING INTO A
I ASKED THE TRAINER HOW LONG HAS
HE BEEN LHERE?? IN!SNAPS IT HOM
IT'S 1-1 GAME! CORNER, HE'S
ALREADY GOT CHABOT ON HIM AND ]
>> IT WAS TIPPED IN FRONT BY
AUSTIN WATSON N
BUT CHANGED DIRECTIONS AND WENT
[ Horn ]
>> John: PARKER KELLELP HIM
OUT.
LOOK IT, YOU JUST TAKE THE
SHOOTER, BUTTAC-TOE.
NO KICKING MOTION.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO TURN THE SKA
PLAYS AND OTTAWA IS JUST,
FOR MONTREALHE ICE.
CAUFIELD SKATES INTO IT.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BREAK STRIDE.
5.
GOES STICK SIDE ON FORSBERG.
NICE PASS FROM EVANS INN
SHORTHANDED GOAL FOR ALEX
FORMENTON
[ Horn ] ACROSS AND
ANDERSON WILL PLAY IT OFF.
HERE'S A CHANCE, WIDEMAN WALKING
IN, AND
FORSBERG.
PEZZETTA IN FRONT WITH A
REM PITLICK PUTS THE REBOUND INT
SEE IT BECAUSE
BACKHAND, AND IT'S THROUGH THE
CREASE.
IT'S PITLICK WITH A SHOT THAT